I haven't been taking burberry for two weeks, and for the past five days I've felt doshes,
loose balls, and crampied. I'm not sure if the burberry is the culprit, because the last time
I took it, I had the same symptoms. But I did not, but I did not make the connection there.
Is there something else I can take? So, burberry is a natural product that's in different foods.
It's found in Orga grape that's found in barberry. It's found in a few other things. It's a great
antibiotic to the gut. It's one of my favorite things that can help lower blood sugar. It's
great for people with cancer, because it can help decrease glucose sensitivity on cell
membranes, so it hinders the cancer cells' ability to take up glucose. It can help kill
H. Pylori, which is a kind of player in so many disorders, really good for heart disease,
burberry, cell, and cardiovascular disease. So I love burberry. I take burberry quite frequently.
But it can be like anything you can kind of have an irritation to it, so it can be good to
pulse your products. Maybe just taking it every day is not the thing to do. Maybe you just need to
take it once a week. Maybe you've taken a couple of times a week. Burberry might still be the
right thing for you to take. Maybe you just, everybody thinks you have to take your supplements every
single day. So, and I might even recommend people take two a day of these. But the truth is,
is that you could have the experiment with a little bit of pulsing your supplements. So my
pulsing, I think I have an article about pulsing supplementation as a blog post on our website
to look. You can search for it at the search bar on our website. The pulsing your supplementation
means sometimes it's good to take it, you know, just four days a week or five days a week, or
you're taking the weekend off. If you notice a sense, to your reaction to any supplement, then it's
can you could even pulse it a little bit differently. Sometimes people are actually having a tummy ache
from the capsule itself. So you can open up most supplements in the last of time release supplements.
You can open up those supplements and put them in your smoothie. You can put them in some other drink.
So I would try pulsing it before I would just discontinuing it. Can a person have a sensitivity
to burberry? I've not known that. Anything is possible. Could you have a damaged gut
border that it's just being irritated by burberry? That's possibility too. Could the loose balls
and bubbles end cramping because because the burberry is killing off age parlorae or something. And it
actually be a good thing. Well, that's a possibility too. But that's no fun to ham. So pulsing it
could be better to maybe just kill a little more slowly if that is the cause of this. We just don't
know you have to experiment with some of those things like that.